uh related to all of this election
misinformation disinformation propaganda
is
this news that dominion the voting
machine uh company
is
not only have they sued uh mike lindell
not only have they sued rudy giuliani
not only have they sued sydney powell
they are now suing newsmax
oan
and patrick byrne who is the ceo of
overstock.com
so someone who is fundamentally
committed to anti-democratic principles
patrick byrne owns a company out there
that you may or may not do business with
and you may or may not want to know or
have that information
reading from the insider dominion sues
newsmax oan and overstock ceo patrick
byrne for promoting election conspiracy
theories dominion voting system sued
newsmax and one america news network on
tuesday accusing the far-right media
organizations of defamation for pushing
far-fetched conspiracy theories that the
election technology company rigged the
2020 presidential election
republicans love
corporate autonomy
republicans love to treat corporations
like people so they have to be on board
with this lawsuit no
wouldn't you think
tuesday's lawsuit against oan accused it
of engaging quote in a race to the
bottom with fox and other outlets such
as newsmax to spread false and
manufactured stories about election
fraud
end quote
dominion quickly became the focus of
this downward spiral of lies as each
broadcaster attempted to outdo the other
by making the lies more outrageous
spreading them further and endorsing
them as strongly as possible the lawsuit
said it added that although the lies
promoted by oan were quote verifiably
false they were still devastating to
dominion's reputation
and this
on its face seems logical it seems
reasonable it seems like common sense
that their reputation would be impugned
and their bottom line affected by this
they have to show damages
because before the 2016 election
could you have named
a voting a company that ran voting
machines
i could not
and it is because of that publicity is
because of that coverage is because of
these pernicious and sinister conspiracy
theories that we do know their name
this lawsuit does seem to have merit
dominion also accused oan host chanelle
ryan not her real name and christina bob
of amplifying and spreading false claims
about dominion the network deputized
rion as an in-house spokesperson for all
dominion related content the lawsuit
said
dominion began in january by suing
sidney powell as i mentioned
rudy giuliani who claimed dominion has
secret ties to the regime of now dead
venezuelan dictator hugo chavez
and developed technology that flipped
votes from then president donald trump
to now president joe biden
dominion as an aside here
also sued my pillow ceo mike lindell who
pushed versions of that falsehood
so
mike pillow and all of this these this
cohort
of of dum-dums
and uh
purveyors of conspiracy theories they're
all in the same camp and they're all
doing damage to the republic these are
these are patriots
they claim to love the country they
claim to cherish our freedoms they they
they rattle on about the constitution of
the united states and having taken an
oath many of them and they violate that
oath
they violate the
the the possibility that they have
respect for democratic rule when they
are actively
months after a free and fair election
months after they are continuing to
spread
gossip and misinformation whipping their
their followers their adherence into a
frenzy such that they attack the
government
such that there's a violent insurrection
at the united states capital
where people died
where they like i said yesterday erect a
hangman's gallow
chanting hang mike pence
stalking throughout the capitol grounds
nancy pelosi where are you
ominous
dangerous un-american anti-democratic
and where is their leader
to quell this
where is donald trump who's certainly
not uh short for words he's not short on
media appearances he could end this
just like he could have ended the
pandemic early on
instead he so doubt about masks
donald trump could go on fox he could
make the rounds to these idiot networks
he could go on fox news he could go on
newsmax he could go on one america news
and say
stop it everybody we need to come
together insurrection and violent revolt
against your government
isn't the way forward we will beat them
at the ballot box next time
but you know what
donald trump doesn't have the mettle
donald trump doesn't have it in himself
to do the right thing because the right
thing would mean taking a step back from
the spotlight
the right thing would mean not
making it all about donald trump
one of our sponsors is steady md primary
care the easier and more affordable way
to do primary care and they're giving
you 50 off because you are in my
audience you just answer a few questions
steadymd will match you with a licensed
primary care physician that's tailored
to your needs you'll have a one-hour
virtual appointment and start a
meaningful relationship with your new
doctor and from then on your doctor will
be available to you by text phone and
video chat it's not some random doctor
on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients you get the attention
you deserve and they can help you with
anything your primary care doc normally
would it's very cool how it works you
don't need insurance
it's just 99 bucks a month no other fees
or co-pays for visits
take the free quiz and see which doctor
is a perfect fit for you you'll get 50
off your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video